Though you may not have heard of Cameron Boyce
before his tragic passing at the age of 20,
you almost certainly saw his face,
perhaps even earlier than you remember.
While many may recall that Cameron Boyce
was biracial, they may not realize his
grandmother played an important part in American
integration history. The 1954 Supreme Court ruling
Brown v. Board of Education established that the
segregation of public schools was unconstitutional
under the Fourteenth Amendment, ending the
precedent set by Plessy v. Ferguson in 1896.
As part of public school integration, 12
black children, now known as The Clinton 12,
began attending Clinton High School in Clinton,
Tennessee. This monumental change in 1956 created
the state's first integrated public school,
and Boyce's paternal grandmother, Jo
Ann Boyce, was one of those students.
In 2016, Cameron and his grandmother recounted
the event for Disney Channel's Be Inspired short
series for Black History Month. Speaking
to People about the event, Jo Ann recalled,
"All of us, all of our parents, every single
student that walked down the hill with me,
all of our parents wanted us to do better.
They wanted us to have better opportunities,
so therefore education was number one for them."
Cameron was evidently proud of the
work his grandmother and her peers did,
especially since the public's reaction to
the integration was largely retaliatory.
"They looked like they just wanted to grab
us and throw it. They didn't want us at all,
I could just see the hate in their heart."
The young actor told People,
"Things are going to happen in your
life and you're going to face adversity,
but if you grow from that and learn from
that, you're a better person because of
it. [...] How could you not be amazed by
their bravery? She has chosen to forgive,
not forget, and she learned from it and
has just grown from her experiences."
Cameron won a Daytime Emmy Award for outstanding
promotional announcement for the segment.
While many know Cameron Boyce for his acting, he
started as a professional dancer. For seven years,
he focused almost exclusively on
dance before transitioning into
acting. While talking to Young Hollywood
in 2018 about the artform, Boyce noted,
"It actually did come pretty naturally to me.
I, sort of, came out of the womb dancing."
In a 2019 interview with Glass Magazine,
he even called dance his "first love,"
a sentiment Boyce's father Victor echoed in a
June 2022 Instagram post memorializing his son.
Trained in ballet, breakdancing, hip-hop, jazz,
modern, and tap, Boyce kept dancing at the
forefront of his career and life. Projects like
the Descendants trilogy continued to let him flex
his skills even after he pivoted toward acting.
In a 2018 interview with HERO, he explained,
"It's really cool to have that in my back
pocket in case I need it. There [are] so
many roles that require dancing or singing
and you have to be able to do all three."
In addition to using his dance training for
acting roles, he and four childhood friends
formed the dance crew X-Mob. Boyce expressed
to HERO that he considered X-Mob some of his
oldest and closest friends, and the group
continued on even after Boyce's passing.
To celebrate their time with Boyce, X-Mob
posted a longform video to their YouTube
channel featuring clips of the actor dancing
and home videos the group had taken together.
A 2008 Panic! at the Disco music video served
as Boyce's first acting job. In the band's video
for the song "That Green Gentleman (Things Have
Changed)," he portrays the child version of Ryan
Ross, the band's guitarist at the time. Boyce
is the first character on screen, playing with
a set of Russian Dolls as the band's lead singer
Brendon Urie's voice comes out of one of the toys.
In a behind-the-scenes look at the video
uploaded to YouTube by Fueled By Ramen,
audiences can see a young
Boyce talking about being
in a music video for the first time and
the costume he wears to match Ryan Ross.
"The wardrobe is really
funny, I wouldn't wear this."
This was the first of several music
videos Boyce would appear in. Other
than his own work within the Descendants
franchise, Boyce also turned up in the
video for "Hardwired" by Hailey Knox as
the male lead, and is credited as one of
the lead dancers and choreographers in the
video for Hozier's "Almost (Sweet Music)."
After the Panic! at the Disco music video,
Boyce's first silver screen appearance was
in a spin-off of the classic medical soap
opera General Hospital. In 2008, He took on
the recurring role of Michael "Stone" Cates Jr.
in the short-lived General Hospital: Night Shift.
The character was the five-year-old son of
Jagger Cates, one of the main characters in
the second season. Over the course of seven
episodes, audiences can watch the young actor
fine-tune his acting skills as his character goes
on a journey of receiving an autism diagnosis.
While a small role, it started what would become
a fruitful career on TV for Boyce. From there,
the young actor guest starred in
the popular Disney Channel series
Good Luck Charlie and Shake It Up before
landing leading TV roles on the network.
The small screen wasn't the only place
audiences could see Boyce. Before winning
his role in the Adam Sandler-led Grown
Ups, Boyce's first big-screen effort,
director Alex Aja's 2008 supernatural horror film
Mirrors saw him in the role of Michael Carson.
The film's premise involves sinister reflections
killing their real counterparts. Midway through
the movie, Michael's reflection begins to
act odd, causing his parents to be concerned
and paint over all the mirrors. However, this
doesn't work for long, as Boyce's character is
later found scraping the paint off the mirrors
in a trance-like state. Before the movie ends,
Michael's reflection nearly drowns him,
but his mother comes to the rescue.
In 2019, shortly after Cameron's death, Boyce's
father shared an Instagram post that included the
Mirrors poster, which depicts the young Boyce
sitting cross-legged on the floor, seemingly
staring at his reflection in a puddle of water.
Victor Boyce's simple Instagram caption read,
"Cameron's first movie. He never watched it."
The Disney Channel series Jessie was
Cameron Boyce's big break on the network,
giving him his first leading role
in a TV series. He played Luke Ross,
a boy who loves video games and has a particular
fixation with his nanny, the titular Jessie.
"I'm Luke, and you are?"
"Way too old for you."
The series was fairly successful for
Disney, making it to a fourth season
and airing 98 episodes. However, the show
might not have happened at all without an
important conversation between its
lead, Debby Ryan, and a producer.
According to an interview with the Star-Telegram,
as Ryan's previous Disney series, The Suite Life
on Deck neared its conclusion, Ryan and
executive producer Pamela Eells O'Connell
looked at other series for Ryan to star in.
O'Connell had previously worked on The Nanny,
and the concept for Jessie came up as
the two bounced pitches off each other.
Without that conversation, Jessie may not
have come to be, and without the series,
Boyce's first major role may have come
at a very different point in his life.
The shift into a leading role in a TV series
impacted many aspects of Boyce's life. In an
interview with the Emmys website, the actor
said that he started being homeschooled due
to the filming schedule, and that
he even began taking college courses
to learn more about responsibility and
accountability in his career. He recalled,
"All the things you are supposed to learn
after you graduate from college I had to
learn at the ages of 11, 12 and 13. So at this
point in my life I feel that because I was in
that professional work environment
my whole outlook on life changed."
He acknowledged staying in a more traditional
school setting may have changed who he was as
a person, since he wouldn't have had the same
responsibilities he did while starring in Jessie.
Despite everything changing around him,
Cameron Boyce worked to stay grounded
and not fall victim to the complicated
fates of many Disney actors who came
before him. In his interview for
the Emmys website, he explained,
"For the people who view an actor's life as
all glamour and we just want to be famous,
it's a job that we do, just like any crew
member who has a job. We like to do it,
not to be in the limelight. It drives me
crazy when actors lose sight of [reality.]"
Part of not losing sight of reality was
keeping his personal and professional
pursuits apart. He explained that,
once shooting wrapped for a day,
instead of spending the evening reflecting
on his performance, he'd go outside and play
basketball. Speaking with Glass Magazine, Boyce
also reflected that, despite his busy schedule,
he still tried to find time to feed
his love for dancing whenever he could.
While doing an interview with Schön! Magazine,
Boyce discussed that his parents were the ones
to instill in him a wariness about his
path as a child star. This caution helped
Boyce avoid the chaotic and often harmful
situations many other young actors face.
Boyce's death came as a shock on July 6,
2019. Just under a month before the release
of the third Descendants movie, the young
actor was found unresponsive in his home,
which he shared with two of his former castmates.
His family made a statement in
the days that followed, saying,
"Cameron's tragic passing was
due to a seizure as a result
of an ongoing medical condition,
and that condition was epilepsy."
Until the statement made by his family,
it was not widely known that the
actor suffered from the disease.
An autopsy conducted by the Los Angeles County
Department of Medical Examiner-Coroner initially
"deferred" the cause and manner of Boyce's
passing. However, after additional testing,
it was confirmed that the actor suffered a sudden
unexpected death in epilepsy, also known as SUDEP.
In the wake of Boyce's untimely passing, the red
carpet premiere for the third Descendants movie,
which was scheduled to come out just weeks later,
was canceled. A few days before the event, Disney
confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter that instead
of hosting the premiere, they were making a
donation on Boyce's behalf to the Thirst Project.
The company also stated that, after securing
Boyce's family permission, that the broadcast
of Descendants 3 would be dedicated to Boyce.
Boyce's final feature film, Runt, screened in
February 2020 at the Mammoth Film Festival.
In the film, Boyce stars as a teen
named Cal who struggles emotionally
after several difficult events in his life.
Boyce's performance was praised by critics,
with Jordan Elizabeth writing
for Common Sense Media,
"The star commands the screen
with authenticity and depth,
slowly transforming as Cal becomes a shell
of his former self with each violent act."
"And what would you even have done, Borgie? Shoot
them with the gun that you stole from your mom?"
Though Boyce appeared in an episode
of the CBS series Code Black in 2016,
his post-Disney career didn't really
start until after his death. His first
major series after Jessie and Gamer's
Guide to Pretty Much Everything was
the Kathryn Hahn-led HBO miniseries Mrs.
Fletcher, which debuted in October 2019.
Boyce played Zach, the college
roommate of the lead character's son,
Brendan. When speaking to Haute Living
about his experience filming the series,
Boyce discussed how shooting in New
York City helped inspire him, saying,
"New York is by far the most stimulating city
I've been to. I came back home rejuvenated,
and more inspired to make art."
Boyce's final performance came out in March
of 2021 with the release of Paradise City on
Prime Video. Created and written by Ash
Avildsen, the series is a continuation
of the writer's 2017 movie American
Satan. Starring alongside fellow Disney
alum Bella Thorne and Booboo Stewart, Boyce
portrayed Simon, an aspiring young musician.
The series was renewed for a second season,
and Avildsen told Entertainment Weekly that
he had many seasons of the show planned before
the first episodes were even filmed. Sadly,
this would require the showrunners to
recast Boyce, though few concrete updates
on the development of the next season
have been announced as of Fall 2023.
Cameron Boyce famously worked alongside
Adam Sandler in Grown Ups and Grown Ups
2. Boyce played Sandler's on-screen
son, and the two became fast friends.
As part of Adam Sandler's movie deal with
Netflix, the comedic actor made the horror
comedy Hubie Halloween. The movie follows Hubie,
played by Sandler, as he watches over Halloween
festivities in the town of Salem, Massachusetts.
The film was meant to mark Sandler's reunion with
his former co-star, as Boyce was originally
cast as one of Hubie's teen coworkers.
However, Boyce's death resulted
in the part being recast only a
few days before the movie was set
to begin filming. In his place,
Boyce's friend, roommate, and Jessie
co-star Karan Brar was cast in the role.
The film included a tribute to Boyce
during the credits. As an image of Sandler
and Boyce appeared on screen, a heartfelt
caption materialized beneath, which read,
"Gone way too soon and one of the kindest,
coolest, funniest, and most talented kids
we knew. You live on forever in our
hearts and are truly missed every day."
Like many actors, Boyce was a philanthropist and
worked with many organizations. In his time in
the spotlight, he raised awareness for causes
such as helping impoverished communities gain
access to clean water and trying to end
violence on college campuses nationwide.
Starting in 2014, Boyce was actively involved
with United Way of America's HomeWalk,
which works to end homelessness. He raised
money for the organization through various
campaigns, including offering personal
shout-outs to others raising money,
and he participated in the opening
ceremonies for the 12th annual
HomeWalk in Los Angeles in May 2019
alongside fellow actor Jon Huertas.
"Every year this makes a big difference,
so I'm really proud to be here.
The HomeWalk that year raised
over $1.1 million and saw more
than 100,000 people participate
in the five-kilometer walk.
Boyce also teamed with It's On Us, an organization
that aspires to end sexual violence on college
campuses. The actor spoke on behalf of the
organization at the 2019 Biden Courage Awards,
which was hosted by the Biden Foundation
and It's On Us. The ceremony recognized
individuals working toward the organization's
mission through intervention, organizing,
and policy change. Through his work with It's On
Us, Boyce even met the soon-to-be-President Biden.
At the time of his death, Boyce was working with
Delaney Tarr, co-founder of March For Our Lives,
on a social media campaign contributing
to the effort against gun violence called
Wielding Peace. The campaign featured
images of public figures, civilians,
and victims of gun violence holding household
objects and art supplies as if they were guns.
In a letter shared by a representative, Boyce
explained this concept, and wrote that the goal
of the campaign was to inspire people to seek
alternative outlets, such as art or fashion,
through which to express themselves
rather than turning to a deadly weapon.
The initial photographs, which were later
published by the Cameron Boyce Foundation,
featured Boyce and his roommates
Karan Brar and Sophie Reynolds.
The campaign continued on, with Descendants
co-star Dove Cameron participating in a Wielding
Peace campaign to remember Boyce on his 21st
birthday in 2020. In conjunction with the Cameron
Boyce Foundation, a merchandise collection
featuring the tattoo Cameron got in honor of
the initial campaign helped raise money for both
the foundation and The Actors Fund COVID Relief.
One of the organizations Boyce regularly
worked with was the Thirst Project,
which works to bring clean water to
underdeveloped countries. In 2017,
the young actor used his platform on
Instagram to help raise $27,000 in 40 days.
Boyce continued to work with the Thirst Project
until his death, being honored by the organization
in 2018 with the Pioneering Spirit Award after
raising more than $30,000 to help build two
wells in Eswatini. Speaking with Billboard, Thirst
Project's CEO and founder Seth Maxwell explained,
"It was more than an honor for
the money he raised for our work;
it was really an honor for a person who knew
no bounds in giving of his time and energy."
After Boyce's death, Adam Sandler hosted a
Facebook fundraiser for the organization,
which helped raise over $15,000
to build additional wells.
Later in 2019, during the tenth annual Thirst
Gala, the Thirst Project renamed the award
Boyce received as the Cameron Boyce Pioneering
Spirit Award in honor of the actor's memory
and his lasting work with the organization.
That year, his roommates presented the award
to Craig Thompson, a YouTuber who raised
more than $150,000 to help build wells.
In an effort to celebrate Cameron
Boyce's memory and philanthropic work,
the Cameron Boyce Foundation was started in 2019.
"The Cameron Boyce Foundation honors
Cameron's legacy by aiming to cure epilepsy."
The Cameron Boyce Foundation helps fund research
and spread information with its Now What campaign.
The campaign's goal is to help newly diagnosed
individuals make more informed decisions about
their epilepsy and provide a tool kit that can
help patients decide what comes next for them
both in their lives and regarding their
health. Based on its 2022 Impact Report,
the foundation boasts that more than 800 members
are now part of the Now What support group.
In addition to working to increase awareness
and research for epilepsy, the Cameron Boyce
Foundation also celebrates and supports the
other causes Boyce worked for in life. After
the 10th annual Thirst Gala, the foundation
donated $8,000 to build a well in Uganda.
The organization credited the donations
from their supporters for making the
significant donation possible, and pledged
to continue the Thirst Project in Boyce's
name. Much like the Wielding Peace
photos, information about the Thirst
Project remains on the foundation's
website under the page Cam's Causes.
The Board of Directors includes
Boyce's parents Libby and Victor,
and Boyce's former castmates Peyton List and
Debby Ryan. Former castmates Dove Cameron,
Sofia Carson, Booboo Stewart, Adam
Sandler, Karan Brar, Sophie Reynolds,
and Descendants director Kenny Ortega are
part of the foundation's Advisory Board.
The Cameron Boyce Foundation started
an annual gala, The Cam for A Cause:
A Fundraiser for The Cameron Boyce Foundation
to End Epilepsy, in 2022. The gala raises
money that the foundation uses to help
fund epilepsy research. Those who knew
Boyce and other invited parties attend the
event and speak to the foundation's goal,
share their memories of the late
actor, and support epilepsy research.
In 2023, the gala included the awarding
of the inaugural Youth Empowerment Award,
a distinction given to a young individual who
is making a difference in the world. The award
is being used as a way to honor Boyce's
legacy and the work he did in his life.
Yara Shahidi, the first recipient, is
known for her appearance as Tinker Bell
in Disney's recent Peter Pan & Wendy movie
and starred in the series Black-ish and
Grown-ish. Discussing how Shahidi earned
the award, The Hollywood Reporter wrote,
"[Shahidi] will be celebrated for her activism
surrounding STEM awareness, women's rights,
civil rights, and her countless acts of kindness
towards others, according to the foundation."